so last night in what somehow managed to
be
one of the most sickeningly cynical and
fraudulent displays we have ever seen
on the floor of congress and i
understand what a statement that is
a group of democratic representatives
decided to hold a group therapy session
um as the lockdowns continue to [ __ ]
american businesses millions of our
citizens face
financial ruin and our nation faces a
host of crises from multiple fronts the
democrats
still carved out some time to talk about
their feelings
their favorite subject after all this
special house hearing was requested by
alexandria casa cortez whose own
cinematic tale of narrowly avoiding
death at the hands of right-wing
assassins took a major hit when it was
revealed that
the riot was happening in an entirely
different building from the one she was
in
nonetheless cortez was given more time
and space
on the taxpayer's dime in this case to
spin her yarn
so here she is introducing the evening's
program while
unabashedly labeling herself and her
colleagues as
survivors listen less than 29 days later
with little to no accountability for the
bloodshed and trauma of the sixth
some are already demanding that we move
on
or worse attempting to minimize
discredit
or belittle the accounts of survivors
in doing so they not only further harm
those who were there that day
and provide cover for those responsible
but they also
send a tremendously damaging message to
survivors of trauma
all across this country survivors yeah
aoc is as much a survivor of this riot
as i am
she was never in any direct danger she
was never confronted by any mob
she did not survive anything except in
the general sense of having made it
through another day without dying in the
sense that we're all survivors
by virtue of the fact that we're all
still currently alive if that's what she
means then fine you know i'll wear the
label too i'm a survivor
someone cue the beyonce song now aoc was
joined in this spectacle by such
squad luminaries as corey bush and
rashida talib the former
vacillated between openly weeping and
boldly declaring that she would have
personally whooped the asses of any
rioters who tried to
cost her so here she is making that
claim
madam speaker st louis and i rise to
reflect
on how our office experienced the white
supremacist attack
on our nation's capital on january the
6th
everybody is everybody's experiences are
different
and everybody's experiences must be
validated
so i remember sitting in the office with
my
team and just thinking to myself
i feel like i'm back at this very minute
i feel like i'm back
i feel like this was one of the days out
there on the streets when the white
supremacists would show up and start
shooting at us
this is one of the days when the police
will ambush us from behind
from behind trees and from behind
buildings and all of a sudden now we're
on the ground
being brutalized it felt like one of
those days and i just remember taking a
second thinking
if they touch these doors if they hit
these doors the way they hit that door
if they hit these
doors and come anywhere near my staff
and i'm just going to be real honest
about it my thought process was
we banging to the end i'm not letting
them take out my people
and you're not taking me out we've come
too far
yeah okay corey you're about to go full
kill bill i'm sure
had the katana ready and everything uh
now and
she says it took her back to the days of
white supremacist shooting at her when
were those days exactly what what is she
referring to that's a that's a headline
i'd like to know what what
happened she says that when they were
shooting at us apparently this is
something that happened to her
i'm not aware of that story notice too
she casually labels the
rioters white supremacists as she has
from the beginning
this isn't very interesting as she
thinks everything is white supremacy
she'll probably label a
literal jar of mayonnaise a white
supremacist but even so
it bears repeating that there's no
evidence and never was any evidence that
anything that happened on january 6
was at all racially motivated
for her part rashida talib could barely
speak
through her tears so overcome with
emotion
even though she wasn't even in dc on the
day of the riot
let's listen to that so what happened on
january 6th
all i could do is thank allah that i
wasn't here
i felt overwhelming relief and i feel
bad for alexandria so many of my
colleagues that were here
but as i saw it i thought to myself
thank god
i am not there i saw the images that
they didn't get to see until later my
team and i decided at that point
we'd keep the death threats away we try
to report them document them to keep
them away from me
because it just paralyzed me and all i
wanted to do
was come here and serve the people
that raised me now she mentions earlier
in her speech
the death threats that she's gotten
during her career which have nothing to
do with the riot
but death threats to a congresswoman or
to anyone else or horrible
um i could tell you that i know that
from experience i myself have had plenty
of them
i've gotten messages plenty of messages
saying terrible things about not just me
but my wife and my children
i've had violence threatened against
against my kids
it's very upsetting to endure something
like that i know from experience
and the people who make these kinds of
threats or send these kinds of emails
are vile filth the lowest of the low
the point simply is that this happens to
anyone in the public eye as a
consequence not of systemic racism or
anything like that but of living in such
a tribalized society
another consequence of living in a
tribalized society ironically
is this display on the house floor this
is political stage craft
disguised as raw human emotion
for proof of that if you need it here
finally is representative dean
phillips in what was hailed as a moving
and powerful speech
but what was really one of the most
shamelessly cynical diatribes we have
ever heard in such a forum
here it is we know what it feels like
searching for something anything
with which to defend ourselves and
realizing
a pencil is about all we had
and we know what it feels like thinking
that it's a real
possibility that we would not see our
families and loved ones
again we won't forget
we won't forget but i'm not here this
evening
to seek sympathy or just to tell my
story
rather to make a public apology
for recognizing that we were sitting
ducks in this room as the chamber was
about to be breached
i screamed to my colleagues to follow me
to follow me across the aisle to the
republican side of the chamber
so that we could blend in
so that we could blend in for i felt
that the insurrectionists who were
trying to break down the doors
right here would spare us
if they simply mistook us for
republicans
but within moments i recognized that
blending
in was not an option available
to my colleagues of color
so i'm here tonight to say to my
brothers and sisters in congress
and all around our country i'm sorry
i'm sorry give me a break dude
i mean it's really quite brilliant if
also completely dishonorable and
disgusting
he implicates all of his republican
colleagues in the riot
positions the ride as somehow racially
motivated
and pretends to humble himself while at
the same time engaging in naked
self-aggrandizement
all in the span of 90 seconds it was the
whole thing was the whole show the whole
therapy session was in some ways a
master class
for those who are utterly soulless and
care for nothing but power
now if you're not in that category
though you will be revolted by the
display
especially when you consider that these
very same people
did not care to hear the stories of
trauma from their own
constituents who lived through much
worse much more damaging much more
deadly rioting sustained for a much
longer period of time
yes i'll say it again i'll say it a
thousand times the rioting that happened
in our cities
was much much much worse
than this and the fact that this
happened to politicians
does not make it worse unless you
believe that politicians
are more worthy or worth more have more
value
than just regular citizens i don't
believe that
our members of congress endured an
unpleasant few hours one afternoon
i admit that none of them were ever
harmed in any way
afterwards they were flanked by national
guard fortified behind protective
barriers
the world cared about what they went
through the system responded forcefully
because after all these are these people
are the system
and the people responsible are being
hunted down and hit with every possible
criminal charge
okay so that's been their experience for
advocate average americans though
in towns like kenosha minneapolis
atlanta
any of the hundreds of other cities for
them portland seattle
it's been quite different in many cases
their neighborhoods are still in ruins
and nobody cares nobody's talking about
it the people responsible have not faced
justice
if they were arrested at all their
charges were dropped
i mean they went through weeks and weeks
and weeks of chaos violence and
destruction and when it ended
nobody helped them pick up the pieces
nobody's bringing them up on the house
floor to shed their tears under the
spotlight
they suffer alone and they are forgotten
even the people who are ostensibly on
their side or too cowardly
or too stupid to really help after all
the republicans could have done
what the democrats just did they could
still do it
they could have brought the victims of
blm rioting to congress
and set aside an hour or more for them
to speak and tell their stories
to reveal their lived experience
or republicans are too incompetent or
else disinterested or else plain
dumb to do something like that and so
the very people who normalized writing
and cheered it on and created the
situation
that we now are in get to make
themselves
the victims of it talk about privilege
what we saw on the floor of the house
last night that's it
that's what privilege looks like well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content